more positive signs from the state of
New York not great still people are
dying we want everyone to live but as
hospitals a hospitalization rates they
are now at its lowest point since the
beginning of this crisis in the state of
New Jersey the number of patients on
ventilators is decreasing in Oklahoma a
hospital is closing due to a lack of
patients in Louisiana all of an update
from Senator Kennedy in a minute numbers
from Wednesday show fewer state
hospitalizations fewer patients on
ventilators and fewer new cases reported
now deaths remain high in several
hotspots but remember experts have been
saying the death rate is the lagging
indicator of the disease you hope for
the plateau then the precipitous drop if
the patterns hold now if these trends
continue it appears that kovat 19 is now
leveling off in the united states the
next step is what we are hoping for a
dramatic drop we can't take our eye off
the ball this country must now plan for
a new massive challenge simultaneously
how do we safely get this economy up and
running as quickly as possible Wall
Street Journal pointing out based on the
latest analysis from America's leading
public health experts politicians can
stop comparing Kovan 19 world war two
but can their war on the US economy be
halted in time to prevent irreparable
damage this country cannot print money
indefinitely that's just a fact - at
some point in the near future
safely businesses must reopen Americans
must return to work and to their credit
the American people want to get back to
work that's what they do best but if we
don't figure out how to do this quickly
and safely the country will see
long-term economic suffering on a
massive scale we've got to prepare to
transition to safely getting back in the
workplace already just this week we got
more massive jobless numbers keep in
mind and this is important whether or
not this virus rebounds is not a
question of if the doctors the experts
they're telling us it will reimburse it
will rebound we can prepare ourselves
for this so the question is how do we
get Americans back to work
safely the answer is not simple in every
case the solution will likely be
tailored to different communities all
across the country in many places with a
highly with a high population density
like New York City mass gloves elbow
bumps compulsive hand-washing will
probably be the new normal for this
foreseeable future if we want to keep
the country running for areas with less
population density this transition it
could be much easier the real key to
doing this safely and successfully is
going to be testing now we'll be asking
dr. oz tonight how do we open up America
and prevent that rebound incredible
innovation by Abbott Labs and this is
incredible testing these guys deserve a
lot of credit for this this has now led
to a test we now know can determine
positive cases of copán 19 in as little
as 5 minutes negative cases around 13
minutes the test is conducted on a
lightweight platform as you can see
they're about the size of your toaster
and to date Abbott has the capacity to
determine 50,000 results each day soon
they will be up to two million now if
businesses in New York and elsewhere if
they're if we are capable of
implementing using this Abbot test
widespread testing that capacity we do
need to increase it dramatically that's
going to be I think the tipping point in
all of this in the meantime other
measures could involve digital
temperature checks and continued
telecommuting and teleworking for those
who are able in other words essential
personnel go in non-essential they can
work from home and do a great job it's
working on my team my staff here at Fox
widespread antibody testing could also
be a very critical tool in getting
Americans back to work and as we move
forward with this strategy it is
critical that patient privacy
constitutional rights civil liberties
they must be protected this is the
United States of America we have a
constitution for example there cannot be
and I have read people are afraid of any
type of government record or government
database now there is no such need for
such a privacy invasion none whatsoever
medical privacy
be in the forefront patient privacy
protected civil liberties must remain
intact we can do both now still a major
question remains even with these
strategies okay how do we get people
into restaurants again safely how do
they reopen their dining room doors how
about movie theaters what about sporting
events and concerts and venues what
about the airline industry these are not
simple questions here how do we get
every sector of the economy back up and
running without jeopardizing the safety
of the American people and subsequently
some type of rebound